beaucoup beaucoup
un bon état d'esprit collectif des
moments très conviviaux
et un entretien physique les exigences
quand même pour ce sport chez au foot
par exemple il faut énormément courir au
judo faut être solide dans les joues
c'est quoi un petit peu les capitales
pour être un bon jouteur j'ai envie de
dire c'est complet c'est complet il faut
de la force du cardio
de l'agilité
c'est très complet
en tout cas c'est un sport qui se
pratique très différemment selon la
méthode qu'on choisit il y a alors il y
a 7 méthodes différentes si je me trompe
en France vous en pratiquez trois
différentes trois et donc selon la
méthode il y a des règles différentes la
position les bateaux ne sont pas les
mêmes et les lance ne sont pas les mêmes
on va dire que là vous vous venez
d'obtenir un titre je dis peut-être une
bêtise là c'est en alsacienne
donc vous avez déjà quatre titres en
parisienne là c'est votre troisième
titre en alsacienne ça fait 7 en tout
mais bizarrement vous avez surtout envie
vous de vous frotter à la lyonnaise
gibordiale
c'est pour ça
c'est là où la méthode où on fait le
grand écart avec des grandes Lens celle
qu'on voit actuellement
pour la faire ou non non j'ai mis 9 mois
j'ai mis 9 mois pour le faire le grand
écart et donc en fait
de passer d'une méthode à l'autre c'est
parce que
une méthode
[Musique]
forcément parce que je suis curieux et
je suis un passionné de ce sport et bah
si je peux essayer toutes les méthodes
je le ferai
on peut être du coup dans une méthode et
pas dans l'autre ou alors la passerelle
se fait assez facilement naturellement
c'est très compliqué de perfectionner
dans une dans plusieurs méthodes c'est
très dur c'est de en général on a sa
méthode principale et on essaie de
s'améliorer dans dans les autres en
général et
titre de champion de France
donc être champion de France c'est quand
même le Graal on joue nautique il y a
pas de compétition internationale on est
d'accord que suprême et comment on
atteint ça justement beaucoup de
sacrifices beaucoup d'entraînement
faire attention à son physique beaucoup
s'entraîner sur les bateaux et après le
reste c'est dans la tête
le climat par la météo donc il y a une
saison sur l'eau mais qui est très
courte c'est celle des compétitions et
il y a on va dire la basse saison les
mauvaises saisons où là on va
s'entraîner dans un gymnase j'imagine
mais
pas en février
je laisse ma place je laisse ma place
non après c'est plus l'hiver voilà ça va
être plus de l'entraînement physique
alors du cardio de la salle de
musculation et toujours entretenir sa
souplesse
et du coup une fois qu'on arrive sur
l'eau on entre très rapidement dans les
compétitions on a le temps de s'ajuster
on a le temps de répéter tous ces gestes
en général on commence les entraînements
courants avril suivant le temps sinon on
commence en mai quelques soient le temps
parce qu'il faut bien se bien se régler
et après le début juin les compétitions
commencent et là c'est parti on est sur
l'eau tous les jours
il y a pas de soleil